welcome back I shouldn't try to squeeze
in videos because then I rush and then
you won't learn and everything breaks
down so problem number seven a B and C
are different positive integers and two
to the a times 2 to the B times 2 to the
c is equal to is equal to 64 and they
want to know what is 2 to the a plus 2
to the B plus 2 to the sea well here we
can just the two things we can use we
can use our exponent rules where we can
if we have the same base and we multiply
it we can just add the exponents right
so this is equal to 2 to the a plus B
plus C and then can we write 64 as a
power of 2 sure let's see 2 2 to the 2
to the third is equal to 8 and 64 is 8
squared so if we square both sides of
that so that's two to the sixth and you
might already know that two to the 62 64
two to the sixth all right and you could
think in a 2 to the fifth is 32 to 62 64
of course so a plus B plus C has to
equal 6 a plus B plus C is equal to 6
and what do they tell us a B and C are
different positive integers they're
different positive integers so what are
a B and C well let's see they could be
one two and three right because 1 + 2 +
3 is equal to 6 alright so there we have
it a B and C or 1 2 and 3 so 2 to the a
plus 2 to the B plus to the sea is the
same thing as 2 to the 1 plus 2 squared
plus 2 cubed and that's equal to 2 plus
4 plus 8 6 plus 8 is equal to 14 and
that is choice a next problem I'll
switch colors for variety problem number
8
in the xy-plane the center of a circle
has the coordinates 3 comma minus 7
let's see if I have to draw this if one
endpoint of a diameter of the circle is
minus 2 comma 7 to the endpoint endpoint
of the diameter this is Center what of
the coordinates of the other end point
of this diameter well sure maybe I'll
draw it for you so just so you get a
sense so all of this action is going on
in so that's the and then see the center
is 3 comma negative 7 so if this is 3
let me do a more different color 3-7 so
this is the center and this one diameter
is at negative 27 so this one diameter
is at negative 27 negative 2 negative 2
minus 2 and then 7 positive set actually
I drew this too big so this is one
endpoint so actually the circle is going
to be huge it's going to be actually let
me let me redraw this because it's going
to be a huge circle let me I didn't I
didn't do this appropriately this is the
coordinate axes draw it big like this so
the center the center i'll not do it in
a different color the center is at 33
and then minus seven right and then one
endpoint is that minus two is it minus
two oh no you know what Ivor I'm misread
the problem the other endpoint is at
minus two minus seven so the other
endpoint is here minus two minus two
minus seven so it's like here sorry I
could use this I could use this graph so
the other end 4 is minus 2 minus seven
shows you how important it is to read
these problems properly right so if you
drew the circle the circle actually
looks
something like this whoops all right but
the important thing to realize and you
actually didn't even have to draw the
circle is that this diameter this is the
diameter that they're talking about and
I know I'm drawing it kind of funny but
this is the point right here 3-7 this is
minus 2 minus 7 so to go from this point
to this point we went we didn't change
our Y coordinates right we just changed
x and what did we do we went how far
back we went from x equals 3 2 x equals
minus two so we went 5 back right so the
other endpoint of the diameter we just
have to go 5 in this direction so if we
start at x equals 3 we're going to end
up with x equals 8 and then the Y is
going to chase stay the same because
we're moving horizontally so it's 8
negative 7 and that is choice E sorry
from just reading it at first but that
shows it can happen to the best of us no
just kidding I'm not even the best of us
alright next problem 9 a regulation for
hiding a certain a regulation for not
hiding for writing a certain amusement
park ride requires that a child be
between 30 inches and 50 inches tall so
between 30 so height has to be greater
than 30 and less than 50 inches tall
fair enough which of the following
inequalities can be used to determine
whether or not a child's height
satisfies the regulation for this ride
ok so they are essentially just
rewriting this equation and saying as as
absolute value with and the number line
could probably be useful here so if I
say that's my number line this is 30 and
this is 50 we know just from this
inequality that you know my height can
be anywhere around here and whenever I
see these absolute value problems
they're really kind of picking kind of a
median or the middle point between the
two and and they're using the absolute
value to say well my did
distance away from that middle point
can't be more than a certain amount so
what you can do is you can pick the
middle point if you want to convert this
into an absolute value equation you pick
the middle point so what's the middle
point 30 plus 50 is 80 the middle point
is 40 right I should have been able to
in my head because it's 10 away from
each other and so we can say instead of
saying that the height has to be greater
than 30 or the height has to be less
than 50 we could all we could say that
the height the difference between the
height and 40 the difference between the
height and 40 and its absolute value
right we don't care if the height is
less than 40 or greater than 40 but that
absolute Vallot that absolute distance
between the height and 40 can't be more
than what well we can't go more than 10
to the positive and we can't go more
than 10 to the negative right so the
absolute value has to be less than 10
that's how you should compute if you
wanted to convert this to absolute value
and how they tended to on the s80 pick
the average point and then figure out
how far can you vary from the average
right the average point was 40 and you
can vary at most 10 so the difference
between the height and 40 can at most be
can be no has to be less than 10 this
could have also been written as 4 u
minus h is less than 10 but the choice h
minus 40 is less than 10 and that is
choice D problem 10
a right circular cylinder with radius 5
and height for has volume V in terms of
V what oh look at that okay so a right
circular cylinder so it looks like this
that's the base that's the top of them
and see this is the top of the cylinder
and then I have you know line like that
and have a line like that and what are
they telling us they're telling us its
radius 5 so this distance is 5 radius 5
height for so height is 4 and the volume
is V try to the radius okay so the
volume is V so what is V equal so v is
equal to you just to figure out the area
of this base actually have a minute left
so i'm going to do problem number 10 in
the next video so let's do not rush it